what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we have some more evidence
that give us
more confirmations about details about
spider-man
no way home if you haven't heard
recently spider-man no way home started
doing some
reshoots they've decided to re-film some
scenes or put in new scenes
and in a weird way this actually kind of
gives us a confirmation that matt
murdock aka
daredevil is actually going to be in
spider-man no way home
and he probably is going to be played by
charlie cox which is something that i
know
just a ton of fans would be super
excited about because a lot of fans
really loved him as
matt murdock aka daredevil in the
daredevil show and if what we have heard
is true this also sets up the premise
for the echo show that is supposedly
coming to disney plus and the rumors
that
daredevil and kingpin will appear in
that show
and as we saw in loki it looks like
marvel really is starting to
plant the seeds for future projects in
the current projects that we're getting
but let's jump into it talk about what
it all means and break it down
and if you're new and you want to stay
up to date on all things happening in
the mcu be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos
so as i mentioned right now spider-man
no way home is going through some
reshoots
and there have been photos online that
do confirm this
there is activity going on in previous
sets that spider-man no way home was
using we have the pictures to prove this
which proves that the movie is indeed
in reshoots right now now some people
are asking
what does that mean for the trailer and
i'm not exactly sure right now i don't
think this will affect the trailer
release
i think at this point with only five
months left till the movie releases
i think they have what they need for the
trailer so for those of you who are
worried that this might push the trailer
release date back
i don't think it will however i still
haven't really been told any type of
confirmation on when to expect a trailer
but of course i'll update if i hear
something
but reshoots are 100 happening right now
and something very
interesting happened charlie cox who of
course played daredevil
matt murdock in the netflix series he
was supposed to appear at celebrity
fan fest in a couple of weeks taking
place on august 7th
and august 8th however yesterday
celebrity fan fest posted this on their
official twitter page
good news and some sad news the good
news tomorrow wednesday 7
21 which is today right now we will make
a new guest announcement for saturday
august 7th
and sunday august 8th this is a very
positive announcement and we think fans
will be excited about this new guest
being added to celebrity fan fest 2021
the sad news unfortunately due to last
minute
filming schedule changes charlie cox
will no longer join us for celebrity fan
fest but don't worry if you sent in an
item for an autograph or still want to
he's graciously
agreed to make sure everything gets
signed which is nice of him
but let's talk about the fact that they
said due to last
minute filming schedule changes he's not
going to be attending
last minute filming schedule changes
what has
recently begun re-filming as we saw
spider-man no way home who has been
reported by multiple outlets to appear
in spider-man no way home the one and
only
matt murdock and now they're doing
reshoots and now all of a sudden
charlie cox can't appear at celebrity
fan fest because
of last minute filming schedule changes
this can't be a coincidence spider-man
no way home starts reshooting and then
all of a sudden
charlie cox has to cancel on celebrity
fan fest for
a filming conflict a last minute filming
conflict
especially after we've heard the reports
from credible outlets stating that matt
murdock is indeed going to be in
spider-man no way home and if you caught
my video that i did i think
a couple of days ago i talked about a
plot leak and i heard from very credible
sources that this plot leak
is indeed true a lot of what is in it
is going to happen in the movie and if
you recall in the very beginning it
actually mentions matt murdock actually
in the first couple of lines of the plot
leak it mentions him it says peter's
life
is ruined after his identity was
revealed at the end of the last
spider-man movie
spider-man no way home he is now facing
trial and matt murdock
is his lawyer then once upon a time
there was also an account from somebody
who claimed to have
auditioned for a minor role in
spider-man no way home
just as an extra in a classroom and they
did mention that they heard
matt murdock and of course many people
have reported him being in the film
however something i do want to specify
when it comes to matt murdock appearing
in spider-man no way home
and that is nobody has actually
mentioned
daredevil people have mentioned matt
murdock
only and when they talk about him they
state that it
is just going to be him no suit no
daredevil so unfortunately even if matt
murdock is in the film it's not going to
be daredevil so don't expect that but
just having matt murdock and spider-man
no way home as peter's lawyer is going
to be pretty epic
and it does set up a lot of things for
the future it has been reported that we
are going to be getting
an echo series on disney plus and with
that report comes the other reports that
actual daredevil and kingpin are going
to be appearing
in that show as well and this could very
well be the setup for that which again
is great news because that means that
charlie cox is most likely going to
reprise his role as daredevil but in the
mcu
something that we were worried about and
i don't think this is going to happen
for many of the other actors and
actresses for the netflix series i think
this is just a one-off thing
charlie cox was so good at playing matt
murdock and daredevil that kevin feige
thought to bring him back
so it looks like he's going to be
starting off as peter parker's lawyer in
spiderman no way home most likely in the
very beginning of the film
now who knows what's actually going to
happen in the beginning of the movie who
knows
if matt murdock actually wins the case
for peter and he's no longer wanted for
murder
but everybody knows he's spider-man or
maybe he loses and peter has to go on
the run
it's unclear at this point because we
know that peter parker is actually going
to go to doctor strange and ask him to
cast a spell
so people can forget that he is indeed
spider-man so whatever happens in trial
in court
it seems like the outcome is still going
to be everyone still knows that peter
parker is spider-man now he may not be
wanted for the murder of mysterio but
there are probably going to be some
people who even if a court rules that he
isn't
guilty will still probably think he's
guilty because that's just the way that
that goes
and regardless he's just a high school
kid he's going to want to have a normal
life so that's probably why he goes to
doctor strange to have
everybody forget what happened so he can
just live a normal teenage life
but not before having matt murdock as
his lawyer
also if you'd like to know something
very hilarious about the spider-man no
way home trailer
i posted this on my instagram yesterday
and if you're not following me
you should because i post a ton of funny
memes and updates on there before i post
them on here so if you've seen this
you know but if you haven't what's
hilarious is that cinemas
theaters they are now using fan-made
spider-man no way home posters
and actually putting them up in the
theaters
and this is hilarious because this even
shows that the theaters themselves are
even tired of sony not releasing
anything for spider-man no way home not
an official poster
or trailer or really anything besides
the title
and that was a long time ago that was
months ago and there's only five months
left
actually under five almost only four
months left until we get the actual
movie
sony really is making us wait till the
actual movie comes out to really learn
anything about it which to me is just
further proof that this is going to be a
true spider-verse film with tobey
maguire
andrew garfield willem defoe's green
goblin alfred molina's doc ock jamie
foxx's electro
and seemingly now charlie cox's matt
murdock
but hopefully we won't have to wait for
that trailer much longer hopefully it
comes out within the next couple of
weeks i'll update if i hear anything
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video and you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you